hello thank you for those of you who
have survived this long into this
wonderful conference I thought everyone
here would either be gone or asleep but
some people have soldiered on America
weisstein I would like to talk to you
today i misspelled something didn't I
that's not good about a project that
I've been involved with to encode
mathematical knowledge of a more
abstract nature in the entity property
framework of Wolfram Alpha and the
Wolfram language and this is work done
jointly with Lynn Kong who will be
giving the second part of the talk and a
couple other collaborators that I'll
mention here in a moment so as an
introduction the idea we have lots of
data collections in lots of areas we
have mountains glaciers people but in
terms of sort of real real and more
abstract mathematical objects we hadn't
really pushed our system very far to see
what we could do and those are things
that we would really like to be able to
encode and make computable so Stephen
Wolfram and Michael trot had this idea
that an area of mathematics called
function spaces would be interesting
testbed to try this out on so a group of
us starting in december of 2014 and
ending summer this year tried to do this
and this includes crist over who is a
grad student at florida state university
and was also works part-time for us
myself james Mullenix who sitting up
front and has been involved heavily in
semantic math initiatives and Lynn so at
the end of the day this sort of consists
of of three new domains function spaces
and then a more abstract version that we
decided we need to split off topological
space types this is still developmental
in wolfram alpha which means you can't
see it on the website but it is hooked
up in the entity value framework so if
you happen to get a copy of this
notebook and try it some of it might
work even outside the Wolfram network so
some challenges with this particular
domain is that it requires a fair bit of
math knowledge and I'm a physicist
astronomer data collector I'm not
a pure mathematician so in order to do a
project like this you need people who
know math and luckily we have Lynn and
James and Chris to provide that
expertise as in a number of areas
literature's very scattered so it can be
difficult to to go through even for a
human to find out what somebody means
when they refer to something they're
different conventions and the entity
framework of the Wolfram language wasn't
really designed to have kind of entities
that have free parameters floating in
around them supported so those were some
challenges I'm just a little bit of
background really quickly for those of
you who aren't topologist sore analysts
a function space is it's a set of
functions that basically takes goes from
one set to another and it's called a
space because it's it has these
properties in many applications it's
something called a topological space and
it has various notions of measure so
common examples you may or may not have
heard of there's lebesgue spaces spaces
of functions that sort of have natural
Jenner is a shins of norms and there's
ck spaces which are have sort of
continuity and existence properties for
derivatives so that's the first piece
then there's a more abstract version of
which function spaces kind of our
particular instances and that's a
topological space and that's a very
general mathematical object in which
these objects satisfy certain low-level
axioms related to points and
neighborhoods and it appears even in
places like physics and other places so
there's a lot of math that actually
depends on these notions and
terminologies and the two most common
examples of Hilbert space and binocs
base so what did we do well at the end
of the day we collected 126 of these
function spaces almost 40 the
topological spaces and then because it's
important to site which conventions and
such we use we've course collected all
the resources and citations that we'd
used so here let's see let's take a risk
and actually evaluate our work okay
so here in the function space domain is
a set of five of the guys that we have
and you can do things like find out all
the ones that are related to this notion
of lebesgue space and since my
colleagues have been doing this I figure
I'll just show you in all bloody gory
detail too there's the whole list if you
really want to see them there's a
substantial amount of work involved in
these compared to secure rating
mountains as you can see there are many
free parameters and lynn will talk a
little bit about some of the challenges
that he had to go through so here are
some of the properties or actually all
of the properties that we attempted to
curate for these and here is what it
will more or less what it will look like
on the B Wolfram Alpha website once we
get final design approval so you type in
the name of the space or some
representation of it you get its nice
little definition you can see there's
actually annotation so when we mark up
the human readable definition we
semantically encode some of the notation
so we get these sort of annotations for
free we make a little graph which will
have more to say about and you get basic
properties what's its measure space
other notations one particularly useful
thing at least that I have found is that
the notational differences this is a
very common space and there's already
multiple different ways that people
refer to it so we can actually collect
these together and show you who used
what ok norms inner products and so on
alright and I again just to show you so
these are what you see of these nicely
formatted entity blobs you've probably
seen those at a couple other talks if
you look at the input form this is what
the thing looks like under the hood it's
just an entity in the domain function
space and it's got this slightly funky
standard name that Stephen Wolfram
doesn't like but so may change before it
actually gets a release that you can
kind of see what it means and we have
parameters the eponymous people related
spaces and again just to kind of show
you in all its gory detail these is the
complete set of properties that is
curated for this space
okay so one of the unique things I'm not
sure that you can see well enough to to
see it but if you can see it you'll
notice that in this entity standard
named blob there's some type set
notation but inside that notation
there's actually some variables those
are those funny little things with the
dot above and below that's a formal
variable in Mathematica so this is not
just a fixed thing this is we can do a
substitution you know we can just
substitute in a particular value of he
goes to one-third or P goes to 3 or P
goes to infinity and the properties of
this space this is what it would be for
in general in the most general case we
can say that a lebesgue space with
parameter P is a member of these
topological spaces but you can say more
about it for particular values and you
can see that the norm for instance is
some piecewise function depending on the
parameter as you plug in different
please you actually have to be able to
handle that and you switched from in the
infinity case from from an integral like
that to an essential supremum okay so
I've raced through that a little bit i'm
going to let Lin take it from here and
hopefully we'll have plenty of time to
show more examples or answer questions
we're both done and sorry for any static
transferring the microphone hello okay
so I'm going to talk about these
topological species so when we started
this project we put everything all
together so all we both here above space
and the bigger space altogether and
later on we realized some of these
species there are more abstract than the
others or even do the are abstract
species so somehow we separate this
project into to someone's so the one
Eric already introduced a code function
species so lack celebrated space they
are
some concrete ones there are particular
functions a collection of particular
functions with particular properties and
now i'm going to introduce some more
abstract of logical species so most
femoris maybe this Hilbert space or the
Banach space and for them we also have
the properties but you can see here they
have less properties than the functional
species that makes sense because they
are more abstract let's see what he's
really looks for example for the Hilbert
space so lack the function space first
you have the name you have the
description and you have this
relationship graph which I will
introduce a shot after Lee shortly after
and here are the more general
classifications means if you have a
Herbert space you will know is a Banach
space it's a very old space such and
such and there are also some examples
like or what what function species are
like in these topological space you so
for example you can see these lebesgue
space is a special kind of these Hilbert
space and you have these formulator you
have the term lon all the authors and
the end you will have these references
and each of these are clickable let's go
back so these theses like this is all
the properties in detail so first begin
with the names and the example function
spaces as shown on the website so this
is what our data really looks like we
didn't include the formulation date for
this cupboard space will this partially
because he was himself didn't really
reach the name huber space it's like
here is like he about motion some
species has this one
for properties a 12k student just you
just use it in his papers and called we
are in the species in here buzz paper
and lit her on people just called we are
in the space in here was people or in
here bus days later on just cocky about
space and one day we'll hear both
himself went to a conference like these
and he hears the audience and somebody
just talking about the other space and
he just asked one of the neighbors okay
water Hilbert space okay that's it good
ah so one one one thing really want for
about these public or species is this
relationship graph will see here so we
now I use the example for the Banach
space panicvis is one of the most
studied topological space in functional
analysis in start bra in operator
theories so given a space which is a
Banach space we always know it belongs
to these buyer space disparities this
broad logical species and is complete is
normed it has lot of other subscription
protease so in other word for the solar
co species we can help this here are key
structure so you can see at the very top
is a hilbert space and a hilbert space
itself is an inner product space and
also a panic seized and a Banach space
will always be enormous piece and a
normal space will always be accomplished
piece so in this way we combine all
these abstract species together but this
is not the full list of all the
tolerable space in the world these are
only the ones we concerned with in this
project and these are self constant
within this project so it kind of this
graph is not super connected if you can
see here on the left that there are some
species are that
for this polish space and on the right
all these species lives in these
topological vector space well this is
because we okay by doing this we have
combined different notations by
different authors from different
references so some of the authors just
interested in these toddlers call vector
species and some of the authors just
interested in the locally comic species
but in general some of the species are
just the topological space with no
further structure so we combine them
together and we want them to consider
within this project so for every
topological space within our project we
have our own definition we likely we
will use the most acceptable definitions
like for the Banach space is just a
complete normed space and if you select
these is like this node and edge graph
so it's really shows this here ugly
structure now how are we going to use
this our last for example for this the
big space or two we can see you value it
is relationship graph a little bigger so
like like little in the website are
actually already implementing this so
for this ultra space we will we will
know it's a hilbert space also
everything that in red means this l2
space are lies in and everything in grey
means it's not necessarily one of these
days and by our previous graph are we
have a lot of this employee implication
edges how can we make sure that our we
are self contained within our project oh
so Eric made a lot of tests is called
Eric's tests so we just want make sure
we didn't make an error so for example
this is just one of maybe hundreds of
these tasks to make
for everything in the previous graph is
a scrap so let's see oops it seems we
miss the someone so this means we should
have this barrel space to get this
Mickey space but we didn't include them
under these bronner space miss this and
stereotype space all this is not really
a bug it's like we want to show we can
really check our crack knees here so
that's why Eric manually deleted these
two edges on the website for now and
once that product of this project is all
all the references we use so roughly we
have more than one hundred papers and
books for this project we listed them or
F entities on the website now so it's
quite standard for each reference you
have is all in property and we also made
some classes a classifications for these
references like for example you can open
all the functional analysis papers
written down by a particular author or
written down in particular language or
even during particular time so let's see
some examples maybe see these battles
1959 functional analysis papers so this
will give us the paper that better
written in 1959 about this functional
analysis and if you click this paper you
can go to ace own page now i'm going to
introduce some examples from this
product so this product is more than a
regular a more than a entity is really a
computable entity so for example we can
check something we know they are there
there's a famous theorem that are for
any p
equator than one the duo space of our
peace peace is lq we r 1 over P plus 1
or curious one so really over auntie T
t1 knows about this so it knows how to
compute is your space okay now let's try
to compute the duo space of HBO space so
the dose piece of ELQ you or is
something looks much complicated but we
can do the simplification and it's your
piece piece itself and all these
entities can be checked whether enough
they are equal so we check yes our
answer it is equal to these ear piece
piece now there's another thing if if
the by deal of a particular function
space because to itself is called a
reflective space now here we can see
that the do space of duo space is called
by do the by do space of lebryk up a
space isla big pieces itself and we can
check this is true so which means
reflexive space should be one of the
properties for these big piece piece we
are is true we really mentioned this
earpiece piece is a reflexive space next
example so all for a particular function
space we have is inner product if
applicable and we have is norm we have a
are we have is equivalence relation
ships of above the are pure functions
are and which means they are really
computable then so like for the oil to
space
we have now we define two functions F F
and F 2 we can see we can check this f
and f 2 are the members of this r2 space
now let's compute is norm so notice
actually our this entity property table
this pure function itself is not really
computable because we have our own
warframe language extensions like these
ameri space like this the big megger is
not really a computable for now but we
have this nice function from entity or
we can for now make it computable so if
apply this from entity to this go to
norm we were just have this regular l2
norm for for for the real line and we
use just the regular integral to
represent this lebesgue measure lebesgue
integral and we apply this L 2 norm on
those two functions and we can compute
them so we have two pretty numbers which
means it's really computable we can
compute these two numbers okay for this
ultra space we know it's a Hilbert space
so it also has an inner product and we
apply these we apply this inner product
on these two functions it will give us
an answer and we know there's a famous
cauchy-schwarz inequality which states
that the absolute value for the inner
product is less less or equal to the
product of those two norms those two are
two norms so we can see here in our
entity table it's really knows there's
the Kosovars inequality for this epic to
space and we can check and this absolute
value for the inner product is really
less than the product of those are two
norms so it returns true so means things
within our project is self constant and
is
ball in some sense oh the last example I
won't show you is a some new species
called cabinet amore species this
species are really new compared to these
curable species they were only
introduced like in the within 15 or 15
years so there are not many papers or
books really on these species and their
definitions are not super clear so one
challenge about this is the about this
product is we need to compare all these
notations all these terminations within
different references you can see from
here different authors may use different
parameters different authors may use
different notations and even to some
also may use the same parameter those
parameters mean mean different things so
in our per our project we just try to uh
made our things self-contained and
really connected with the other entities
we have in our project and also for this
more space there is a alternative
definition so for this particular space
different authors has different
different internet on our eight so for a
particular same space we have even two
definitions okay thank you i right
that's oh so n question
you